onancock comes from a family of
traditional healers in Greenland no one
here is left unmoved by his prayer song
the big ice changing is the title of
this tour run by his organization ice
wisdom participants have come from
Central Europe and North America for a
week-long spiritual journey at the edge
of the Western Greenland ice sheet the
cost of camping in the wild without
electricity or running water is about
three thousand euros the quest for
spiritual awakening is no longer an
esoteric niche market it's a global
phenomenon clients have different
motives but everyone here is looking to
slow down
I hope to find something within myself
that I can't find in the stress of daily
life a friend recommended this trip as a
way to help me find stillness see
something different
and live in a way that's different to my
normal life it's a search for spiritual
realization enrichment of my previous
experiences spended consciousness I
studied anthropology when I was in
college
and so I'd like to learn a lot about
cultures as well the program includes
several hour long walks
amid the breathtaking scenery they stay
in a group
but are silent and they don't eat each
on his own the goal is to calm the
mental chatter in our heads
most people have lost the connection to
mother nature one day you and I we
should learn to walk we only what we
think and what we feel but because we
are humans what we think is very
powerful the big ice as Greenlanders
call it is another focus the impact of
global warning on the ice sheet is
alarming ananga has long been fighting
to raise awareness about the dramatic
melting representing Arctic peoples on
United Nations panels but to no avail
mankind is like a teenager they don't
care but what's going to happen tomorrow
they care about what we have now it
makes me sad that people don't know how
to listen they don't know how to hear
whether they listening here for if they
begin to listen here it will change but
now it's too late
this big eyes will melt in your lifetime
catastrophe is on its way
attached to the figure now we cannot
even imagine for many participants
first-hand experience of the melting ice
is a moving even life-changing
experience I felt almost a weeping from
it you know the crashing when the ice
breaks and it calves and you hear that
crash and it's a it's a roar it's it's
like thunder but deeper and louder and
more charismatic I felt her from ice
block we all need to become aware of how
we're treating the earth what we're
taking from it and that we're taking far
more than we need that's the more
conscious you become of that the more
care and respect with the earth you will
have respect for my organs Condon you
get a shock and feel you share
responsibility for what's happening
critics of such events say they're
nothing more than commercial adventure
trips sold in esoteric packaging rackets
cloaked by promises of spiritual
awakening uh nanak and the participants
say that's not true
to pump money out of people I'm there to
give them but of course it cost money to
come here because money to establish a
camp so it had to be paid is it part of
a money-making spiritual machine I think
I trust my intuition more than that and
I know the difference the hours long
hike under the Midnight Sun to the top
of a mountain is challenging for all the
participants but no one complains it's
what they came for
and tonight the reward is a special
natural event I don't know if you can
feel the energy this is the Midnight Sun
and this is a full moon completely
opposite of one another
the shamans song that follows will
resonate with visitors long after
they've returned home
Oh
Oh